[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
bettina zimmermann und christian sievers
guten abend hinein auch wenn wir die
lage in der ukraine gerade wie in
echtzeit miterleben per handy videos und
augenzeugen berichten es ist wie immer
im krieg der wahre horror
das ganze ausmaß des grauens zeigt sich
erst später mit verzögerung wenn es
wieder möglich ist mit reportern und
kameras an die orte zu gehen an denen
russland soldaten man muss wohl sagen
barbarisch gewütet haben zumindest gehen
aus einem gebiet nördlich von kiew
grauenhafte bilder um die welt die allem
anschein nach auf systematische
kriegsverbrechen schließen lassen der
beitrag von annegret oster zeigt
erschreckende szenen das als hinweis für
sie vorweg es
gibt keine worte die diesen bildern
gerecht werden können fahrt durch die
straßen von butscher leichen von
zivilisten am straßenrand überall boccia
einst friedliche vorstadt von kiew ist
zu einem massengrab geworden die
überlebenden leben neben den toten die
todesangst noch ins gesicht geschrieben
es war furchtbar
zweimal wäre ich fast gestorben einmal
ist eine kugel durch mein fenster und
ist in meinem kleiderschrank gelandet
das zweite mal ist ein granatsplitter
nur knapp an meinem bein vorbei und
draußen hat ein mann auf mich gezielt
aber er hat vorbeigeschossen
fast einen monat lang war butscher von
der außenwelt abgeschnitten fast einen
monat lang tobten die kämpfer auch viele
russen starben verbrannten in ihren
panzern
sie taten mir leid sie war noch sehr
jung 18 20 jahre alt ihr ganzes leben
hatten sie noch vor sich
jetzt räumt die ukrainische polizei auf
entschärft minen kümmert sich um gas
wasser elektrizität für die lebenden 280
tote sollen den massengräbern beigesetzt
worden sein nur wenige finden eine etwas
würdigere letzter die menschen dankbar
dass alles vorbei ist und jetzt hilfe da
ist ja cool
danke danke für alles ich verbeuge mich
ein berater von präsident selensky
spricht von verbrechen gegen die
menschlichkeit und kündigte ermittlungen
an
in burj al arab in hostel zeigen sich
szenen wie aus horrorfilmen post
apokalyptische bilder
unter den opfern der russischen
verbrechen sind vergewaltigte frauen die
sie versucht haben zu verbrennen
ermordete beamte ermordete kinder
ermordete alte ermordete männer viele
von ihnen mit gefesselten händen mit
anzeichen von folter mit kugeln in ihren
russland dementiert die bilder aus
butter sein eine weitere inszenierung
des regimes in kiew für die westlichen
medien
ihre pin liegt gleich neben butscher die
bilder ähneln sich der preis für den
erbitterten kampf gegen die russischen
invasoren der preis für die verteidigung
der hauptstadt kiew tod und zerstörung
die kleinstadt rost janitz im osten des
landes sie wurde nicht nur geschossen
sondern auch einen monat lang von den
aggressoren besetzt russen vertrieben
die einwohner aus ihren wohnungen
plünderten die supermärkte vorgestern
sind sie abgezogen doch frieden wird
hier noch lange nicht herrschen
christoph reuter kollege vom spiegel war
der erste internationale journalist in
dem kurort trotz der 20.000 einwohner
nachdem die russischen soldaten von dort
abrückten herr reuter guten abend
bemerkt wie haben denn die menschen dort
das erlebt sie berichten dass die
erstmal wie fremde durch ihre eigene
stadt gewandert sind
ja das irre war wir sind ja erst
ungefähr 36 stunden nach dem abzug der
russen in die stadt gekommen nur da die
bevölkerung kein mobilfunknetz mehr
hatte keine lenkt lions erkennen ein
festnetztelefon sich überhaupt nicht
mehr auf die straße traute weil leute
willkürlich erschossen worden waren
wussten die zum teil nicht was geschieht
hundert meter weiter und haben trotz der
totenstille im ort über einen ganzen tag
lang sich nicht aus ihren häusern raus
getraut erst als der ersten ukrainischen
verwende einrücken kam sie raus und als
wir dann kam haben wir diese szenen
erlebt wo menschen auf der straße
langlaufen jemanden sehen den sie kennen
anfangen zu weinen und sie in die arme
fein du lebst und das waren nachbarn die
vielleicht oder leute die 23 500 meter
voneinander entfernt gewohnt haben aber
niemand wusste was ist mit den anderen
was ist den geschehen leben die noch
unglaubliche unvorstellbare szenen jetzt
haben die russen ja in den aller ersten
kriegstagen den ort trotz der netz
bereits eingenommen und besetzt ich habe
schon gesagt ein kurort tschaikowsky hat
dort mal komponiert war denn das so
geplant war da irgendeiner form eine
strategie erkennbar nein also zum einen
nicht weil wir völlig sinnlos mit 600
und mehr soldaten in einen strategisch
unbedeutenden kurort in 30 kilometer
entfernung von der grenze einzurollen
und der hauptgrund dass sie das getan
haben war das eine brücke nördlich von
afrika wo man weitergefahren wäre
richtung kiel in die zentrale ukraine
die vachaer gesprengt worden und dann
ist dieser konvoi am 24 februar am
ersten tag des krieges wieder maßen nach
rechts abgebogen und dann offensichtlich
fehlt ihr bleibt jetzt hier intros und
wartet weitere befehle ab so sind die da
eingeholt und die wenigen ukraine die
mit denen geredet haben die mit ihnen zu
tun hatten die wurden dann von den
russen gefragt nach zwei drei wochen
sagen
haben wir das schon erobert lebt
selensky noch und dann merken die
ukraine den russen wissen selber
überhaupt nicht was im ganzen land
passiert und sie hatten auf zumindest
konnten sie nichts sagen dazu sie hatten
überhaupt keinen plan wohin geht es als
nächstes was wollen wir von diesem ort
wie lange bleiben wir hier das einzige
was die geantwortet haben wenn sie
überhaupt was sagt veh
jetzt haben wir heute heute diese
grauenvollen bilder aus butter gewinnen
kleinen ort nördlich von kiew wie hat
man sich denn die russische
besatzungszeit in dem ort in dem sie
waren vorzustellen
das spannende ist dadurch dass die
russen doch so früher eingegangen sind
und einen ganzen monat daran kann man
dort sehr gut die die kurve
nachvollziehen von soldaten kommen an
diesen ort der nicht teil des planes war
wenn es überhaupt hier ein gab die
lassen sich erstmal im
polizeihauptquartier am bahnhof nieder
haben mit der lokalen bevölkerung nichts
zu tun dann gehen ihnen die vor geklaut
dann gehen ihnen die schmerzmittel aus
dann werden sie nach einer weile von der
ukrainischen armee angegriffen die zum
teil auch durch die bevölkerung die
genauen positionen
ihrer panzer stellung übermittelt
bekommen fünf meter rechts von vassilis
bäckerei und so weiter das heißt die
soldaten geraten unter druck plündern
die häuser plündern die leben plündern
das krankenhaus und haben das gefühl
jeder in diesem ort ist gegen sie was ja
auch stimmt und rächen sich an der
zivilbevölkerung und es gibt
offensichtlich nichts keine befehle von
oben aber auch nichts was sie persönlich
zurückgehalten hat
wahllos menschen zu erschießen zu
foltern in ihr herr keller umzubringen
und im etwas kleineren maßstab wir haben
auch gleichen gesehen aber nicht so
viele wie in botschaft in etwas
kleineren maßstab das zu tun was sie auf
furchtbarste weise in butter getan
jetzt ist die stadt wieder in der hand
der ukraine kann denn der ort jetzt
aufatmen
also der ort ist in eine es ist eine
leicht surreal situation der ist 30
kilometer von der russischen grenze
entfernt das heißt wenn die russische
armee will dann kann sie selbst mit
weitreichender 18 diesen auf weiter
genießen und sehen wie russen wollen
könnten sie dort innerhalb von einer
stunde mit gepanzerten fahrzeugen wieder
sein aber das was die leute trotzdem
aufatmen nächst ist der eindruck den sie
in trotz der netz haben aber auch in
vielen gegenden rund um hpv-viren wo die
russen ebenfalls sich zurückgezogen
haben dass alle sagen die sind so
abgekämpft die haben so viel an material
und auch an soldaten verloren das im
moment hier in dieser gegend im osten
der ukraine
die angst ein bisschen gewichen ist dass
sie so schnell nicht wiederkommen
christoph reuter kollege vom spiegel
herzlichen dank für ihre schilderung
die apokalyptischen szenen aus der
ukraine sind heute auch in den
regierungszentralen des westens gesehen
worden auch dort steigt der druck mehr
druck zu machen auf wladimir putin die
eu will neue sanktionen beschließen der
bundeskanzler verlangt zitat olaf scholz
diese verbrechen des russischen militärs
müssen wir schonungslos aufklären
thomas reichert hat mehr dazu ein paar
stunden bevor olaf scholz abend im
kanzleramt vor die kameras tritt war der
bereits eine pressemitteilung zu
veröffentlichen lassen darin forderte er
die täter und ihre auftraggeber zur
rechenschaft zu ziehen aber zunächst von
ihm kein wort zur weiteren sanktionen
und jetzt wir werden im kreis der
verbündeten in den nächsten tagen
weitere maßnahmen
beschließen präsident putin und seine
unterstützer werden die folgen spüren
und wir werden der ukraine weiterhin
waffen zur verfügung stellen damit sie
sich gegen die russische invasion
verteidigen kann was aber meint scholz
mit weiteren maßnahmen das lässt er
offen
auch außenministerin baerbock die bilder
aus butter unerträglich und kündigt per
twitter an wir werden die sanktionen
gegen russland verschärfen in berlin
direkt wird der vizekanzler konkreter
kündigte sanktionen gegen weitere
personen an noch mehr einschnitte beim
handel mit technischen gütern und dem
finanzmarkt aber am bergweg ein
sofortiges energie embargo
wir arbeiten jeden tag daran jeden tag
ein stück weit unabhängig zu werden von
gas und öl und wir haben 14 15 20 jahre
lang kann deutschland sich abhängig
gemacht von russland innerhalb von vier
wochen drehen wir das jetzt um harbeck
deutet an dass die bundesregierung gegen
die deutschland tochter der russischen
konzern rosneft und gazprom vorgehen
könnte derweil wächst die kritik in
berlin an den energie milliarden für
putin selbst bei der linken die ihn
lange verteidigte es ist natürlich ein
wahnsinn dass auf der einen seite wir
mit jeder lieferung von gas aber auch
von öl und kohle letztlich den krieg
putins mitfinanzieren das ein
furchtbares dilemma es muss eine antwort
geben es muss eine reaktion geben solche
verbrechen dürfen nicht unbeantwortet
bleiben das muss auch putin klar also
stoppte gab sie deswegen muss jetzt im
kreise der eu-minister genau das
miteinander besprochen und das war
bisher unsere stärke die bundesregierung
sagt sie tue alles um schnell
loszukommen von russlands energie
lieferungen für die ukraine das zeigen
die bilder aus butter geht das nicht
schnell genug
wir gehen uns live nach kiew zu unserer
reporterin dort katrin eigendorf katrin
guten namens in kiew hat die russische
armee ihre truppen zurückgezogen du bist
heute im zug dorthin gefahren zusammen
mit menschen die auch wieder
zurückkehren in ihrer heimat mit welchen
gefühlen tun sie das
ja was interessant war der zug war fast
ausgebucht und wir haben dort die
gelegenheit gehabt mit vielen menschen
zu sprechen die wirklich alle mit großen
schmerzen und großer trauer zurückkehren
und großer angst auch wie sie uns
erzählen dass sie gar nicht wissen was
sie dort erwartet dass sie angst davor
haben wie sie hier leben weiterführen
können die
grauenvollen bilder die wir gesehen
haben ausputzer darüber reden die
menschen natürlich auch die jetzt
zurückkehren und sie fürchten dass sie
in einem lande in einem kompletten
ausnahmezustand jetzt dass sie dort
irgendwie wieder fuß fassen müssen denn
sie sagen wir können ja nicht dauerhaft
im ausland bleiben aber diese gräuel zu
dokumentieren das ist natürlich den
menschen jetzt unglaublich wichtig und
ja ich kann nur sagen ich habe so viele
menschen im zug erlebt die wirklich
tränen in den augen hatten sogar geweint
haben die sagen wir sind völlig
verzweifelt wir wissen eigentlich gar
nicht wie unser leben hier weiter gehen
soll und warum fahren sie dann trotzdem
was erwarten sie es ihnen das geld knapp
geworden oder was sind die gründe
das sind sehr unterschiedliche gründe
also einige haben uns gesagt dass ihnen
das geld knapp geworden ist das sieht
auf dauer nicht im ausland leben können
dabei eine frau hat uns zum beispiel
auch gesagt wir die meisten von uns sind
hier am 24
februar hier ganz plötzlich aufgebrochen
haben alles stehen und liegen lassen wir
müssen irgendwann zurückkehren weil die
menschen haben ja auch gar keine
gelegenheit gehabt irgendetwas
mitzunehmen und sie sehen jetzt eine
chance das ist jetzt der erste moment wo
sie wieder in ihr land in ihre stadt
zurückkehren können aber die realitäten
hier sind natürlich grauenvoll und ich
denke das größte bestreben der
ukrainischen regierung ist jetzt das zu
dokumentieren dass der welt
vorzuführen und genau zu zeigen was hier
passiert ist deswegen lädt man jetzt
auch journalisten und auch wir werden
dabei sein zu einer
dazu ein diese gebiete anzugucken das
ist nicht so einfach möglich weil die
größtenteils auch noch vermietet sind
aber auch wir werden gelegenheit haben
uns in butter um zu gucken und dort zu
drehen diese bilder werden wir uns
weiter beschäftigen katrin filler moment
herzlichen dank nach kiel
europa guckt heute gespannte und
durchaus auch angespannt richtung ungarn
da entscheidet sich nämlich gerade wer
das land künftig regiert viktor orban
will eine fünfte amtszeit die vierte in
folge es entscheidet sich auch ob der
zunehmend autoritären regierungsstil in
budapest weitergeht den ihm die eu
vorwirft die meisten medien unter
staatlicher kontrolle die nähe zum
herren im kreml die auch durch den krieg
kaum beeinträchtigt wirkt da steht also
einiges auf dem spiel für ein eu land
sehr ungewöhnlich sind mehr als 200
internationale beobachter vor ort sie
sollen sicherstellen dass die wahl
korrekt verläuft der aktuelle stand
jetzt von wolf christian ulrich
ernüchterung und sorge bei anhängern der
opposition angesichts erster prognosen
ein neuer sieg orban scheint sich
abzuzeichnen
das wäre ein alptraum dann werden viele
junge leute weggehen
ministerpräsident viktor orban gab sich
schon am morgen siegesgewiss
einem großen sieg das ist was dieses
land braucht der kontinent im system
orban ist alles auf diesen grossen sieg
ausgerichtet presse wirtschaft
machtapparat doch dann wurde russlands
krieg für putin partner orban im
wahlkampf zum problem urban zögerte
zunächst bei sanktionen und die
nato-partner mussten ihm die aufstockung
von nato-truppen in ungarn förmlich
aufdrängen
außenministers jato träger des
russischen freundschaftsorden lehnt
waffenlieferungen für die ukraine bis
heute ab
bringt immer risiko und gefahr das ist
in unserer nachbarschaft das ist
gefährlich wir müssen daraus bleiben
orban laviert zwischen ost und west
seine wähler gut ihre dass
ich bin zwar nicht komplett zufrieden
mit der regierung aber ich finde dass in
der aktuellen situation organs fidesz
partei besser ist
angesichts der grauenerregenden
kriegsverbrechen in butter in der
ukraine die weltweit für entsetzen
sorgen deutet orbáns kabinettschef am
wahlabend an
die sanktionen gegen russland nicht
abzulehnen
wir wollen es vermeiden um allein zu
bleiben aber
vernünftiger sanktionen müssen wir
gemeinsam der spitzenkandidat der
ungarischen opposition hatte orban putin
problem zum wahlkampfthema gemacht
wir sind pro und pro nato wir glauben
fest dass ungarns sicherheit von unserer
nato mitgliedschaft abhängt das können
wir nicht verraten wie orban das tat
die opposition hatte es im wahlkampf
schwer für ihre überzeugungen zu werben
denn um seine macht dauerhaft zu sichern
hatte orban das wahlgesetz geändert das
führte dazu dass er vor vier jahren mit
49 prozent der stimmen ganze zwei
drittel der sitze im ungarischen
parlament errang die sechs wichtigsten
oppositionsparteien traten deshalb
gemeinsam an um überhaupt eine chance
gegen orban zu haben spitzenkandidat
peter mark ii sei ein konservativer
wirtschaftswissenschaftler kämpft gegen
die korruption des urban systems
außerdem ist die opposition klar pro
eben
der ich möchte ein ungarn wo die jungen
leute auch bleiben können arbeit finden
und zumindest annähernd gehälter auf
westlichem niveau bekommen
markise gab heute morgen in seinem
südungarischen heimatort die stimme ab
wir kämpfen für demokratie und anstand
für die unabhängigkeit der justiz und
für rechtstaatlichkeit in unseren
die wähler scheinen anders entschieden
zu haben sie werden wohl mit orban einen
mann der sagt ungarn first und meint
urban fest
und noch eine wahl heute auf die wir
schauen sollten und das macht jetzt ganz
genau denn auch in serbien wurde heute
ein neues parlament gewählt und außerdem
fanden präsidentschaftswahlen statt
dabei wird die wiederwahl des
amtierenden staatschefs alexander wetsch
erwartet auch seine rechtskonservative
fortschrittspartei dürfte den umfragen
zufolge ihre mehrheit im parlament
verteidigen coach möchte serbien in die
eu führen war aber bisher auch um gute
beziehungen zu russland bemüht
die bundesregierung hat sich darauf
geeinigt dass mieter die klimaabgabe bei
den heizkosten in den meisten fällen
nicht mehr alleine zahlen müssen künftig
soll auch der vermieter einen teil
übernehmen allerdings abhängig von der
energiebilanz des hauses ab 2023 soll
einen stufenplan gelten ist ein haus
schlecht saniert und gedämmt zahlt der
vermieter einen großteil der co2 abgabe
beim hohen energiestandard e h 55 zeit
er dagegen nichts
bei schweren unwetter im brasilianischen
bundesstaat rio de janeiro sind
mindestens 16 menschen ums leben
gekommen
nach starkregen kam es zu erdrutschen in
der küstenregion ganze häuser wurden von
den schlamm und erdmassen decke rissen
und bewohner verschüttet erst mitte
februar hatten heftige regenfälle
nördlich von rio zu erdrutschen und
überschwemmungen geführt dabei starben
mindestens
234 personen
papst franziskus hat am zweiten tag
seiner weiterreise zu gebeten für die
ukraine aufgerufen bei einer messe vor
tausenden gläubigen in floriana
bezeichnete franziskus den krieg als
sakrileg zum abschluss seiner reise
besuchte er ein aufnahmezentrum für
geflüchtete dort warnte er vor einem
zitat schiffbruch der zivilisation
und dann ist heute ein tag der
eigentlich ein ausrufezeichen bekommen
sollte der tag an dem die allermeisten
corona beschränkungen in den
allermeisten teilen von deutschland
wegfallen ersatzlos es ist ein tag mit
fragezeichen geworden denn die
infektionszahlen sind weiter hoch und
die einen fühlen sich jetzt dem hilflos
dem virus hilfloser ausgesetzt die
anderen freuen sich auf die neue alte
zeit am ende steht eine erkenntnis die
diese phase der pandemie beschreiben
dürfte es kommt jetzt die zeit in der
jede und jeder das risiko selbst
einschätzen muss mehr freiheit für alle
aber auch mehr verantwortung
die fahrschüler
die einen atmen auf andere gehen auf
nummer sicher bremen am nachmittag für
die fußball fans beginnt das prinzip
eigenverantwortung wenn die straßenbahn
türen aufgehen dann endet die masken
pflicht abziehen oder auf lassen sie
sehen ja ich habe meine maske hier bei
mir und tragt ihr auch ich sage mal das
muss jetzt jeder selber wissen wenn man
zum teil ja die inzidenz in den druck
aber wir müssen auch mal lernen mit dem
virus um umzugehen wenn man jetzt so
viele leute um sich man braucht ja
diese bilder sind von heute tausende
strömen ins ausverkaufte weser stadion
trotz inzidenz von 1800 gilt auch im
stadion keine masken pflicht mehr
verkaufsoffener sonntag im bayerischen
rosenheim einkaufen ist in fast allen
bundesländern wieder ohne maske möglich
ich denke
also ich habe mich dafür entschieden mir
wäre es lieber gewesen wenn man in den
geschäften einzelhandel supermärkten ist
nach wie vor trägt
und
das ist auch für jeden praktikabel
rekord incidents prallt auf zurück
gewonnene freiheit in freude mischt sich
sorge bleibt die frage wie gut das
prinzip eigenverantwortung in der praxis
funktioniert stuttgart raichberg
realschule
die schulleiterin zählt die vielen
positiven corona fälle und findet das
ende der masken pflicht riskant vorerst
werden wir mit den klassen reden und
sagen freiwillig dürfte die maske tragen
bitte tut das auch wenn natürlich einer
sagt nee ich hab es jetzt endlich seite
und wird die maske fallen lassen dann
können wir nichts machen der bund hat
das maßnahmen ende beschlossen land und
lehrer empfehlen masken weiter zu tragen
entscheiden werden sie das votum der
zehntklässler
wirklich kopfschmerzen ich muss mich
auch die ganze testen
und deswegen finde ich das mit den
massen er so unnötigen ich werde die
maske absetzen für jeder sehen der ein
problem damit hat soll sie weiter tragen
wir haben schon sehr hohe zahlen und
ohne maske ist es halt noch schlimmer
und so spiegeln sich im klassenzimmer
schon mal aufziehen der konflikte
politisches hickhack und komplizierte
corona regelwerke vorerst passé jetzt
muss sich das prinzip eigenverantwortung
beweisen
eine aufgewühlte welt an diesem ersten
sonntag im april lanka die tropeninsel
bekannt bei urlaubern für ihre
umwerfende natur und für begeisternde
menschen ist in aufruhr x 10 x 16
stunden am tag ist gerade der strom
abgestellt brütende hitze und an den
tankstellen lange warteschlangen der
frust über eine beispiellose
wirtschaftskrise entlädt sich in gewalt
in sri lankas präsident wegen einer
besorgniserregenden menschenrechtslage
bereits international in der kritik hat
jetzt den notstand ausgerufen normen
odenthal
ein staat und seine bürger geraten
aneinander
es brodelt gewaltig an diesem tag
demonstrationen tränengas wasserwerfer
dabei hatte die regierung eine
ausgangssperre verhängt das volk sollte
ruhe geben ruhe die der präsident gern
persönlich vermitteln würde
man sei in guten gesprächen sagt er mit
dem währungsfonds den gläubigern um die
finanzkrise zu entschärfen die schulden
zu drücken bis dahin müssten die bürger
einschnitte bei benzin und energieertrag
keine botschaften die die stimmung
beruhigen das vertrauen ist weg die
verzweiflung da die krise des staates
stürzt die menschen in not
was ist das für ein leben es geht ja um
unsere grundbedürfnisse wie energie
jeden tag schalten sie jetzt für 16
stunden den strom ab es gibt kein gas
kein benzin wir haben nichts zu essen
keine medizin was sollen wir denn tun
sollen wir uns alle ins meer stürzen
aus sorge wird angst aus angst wird und
proteste vor dem präsidentenpalast der
vorläufige höhepunkt der sich
zuspitzenden staatskrise wie konnte es
soweit kommen an dem die ausbleibende
tourismus das hat die wirtschaft
getroffen aber sri lankas probleme
liegen tiefer es ist eine krise mit
ansatz
die regierung hat lange zeit das ganze
geld in unser projekt steckt die haben
straßen gebaut auf denen keiner fährt
wir haben flughäfen gebaut wo keine
flugzeuge landen geisterstädte wo keiner
wohnt autobahnen auf denen nur elf an
oder so laufen
es ist eine bizarre liste von teuren
mega projekten allesamt in den sand
gesetzt korruption geltungssucht
misswirtschaft wie aus dem bilderbuch
mit ausländischen krediten finanziert
die jetzt nicht mehr bedient werden
können
unsere kreditwürdigkeit wurde komplett
herunter gespielt wir sind auf ramsch
niveau kann man sagen keiner leitung ist
nervös deshalb haben wir angefangen geld
zu drucken das war unser schlimmster
fehler der alles zum kippen gebracht hat
inflation lebensmittelpreise etwa sind
im märz um 30 prozent gestiegen importe
aus dem ausland sind nicht mehr zu haben
das wenige was es gibt wird teurer und
teurer
überall nur schlangen jetzt stehe ich in
der diesen schlange heute morgen stand
ich in der milch- pulver schlauer
wenn ich morgens aufwache kostet alles
das doppelte und meinem lohn kann ich
also nur noch halb so viel kaufen ich
verdiene so viel wie früher aber es
reicht nicht mehr bei diesen preisen
die prognosen sind düster für die bürger
und den start sri lanka droht die
zahlungsunfähigkeit und noch unruhigere
zeiten
an zu lang hats schulen wurden zuletzt
die prüfungen verschoben die bögen mit
den fragen konnten nicht gedruckt werden
weil es auch an papier fehlt ein
politologe aus sri lanka sagt der faz
wir haben den bürgerkrieg bewältigt
einen verheerenden tsunami terror und
die pandemie wir haben uns immer wieder
auf aber dafür brauchen wir eine fähige
politische führung
und jetzt in der sendung normal habe und
zwar mit fußball in der ersten
bundesliga gab es heute nämlich zwei
begegnungen mit folgenden ergebnissen
der fc augsburg holte sich drei punkte
mit einem 3 zu 0 gegen den vfl wolfsburg
borussia mönchengladbach und der erste
fsv mainz 05 trennten sich 1 1
unentschieden und jetzt noch die
wetteraussichten morgen im norden
kräftiger regen im osten und im bergland
teils mit schnee vermischt dazu starker
südwestwind mit schweren sturmböen im
süden trocken und sonnige abschnitte 4
bis 10 grad auch in den nächsten tagen
sehr wechselhaft mit viel regen bei
teils stürmischem wind dienstag 6 bis 11
grad danach allmählich wieder milder
ja windige aussichten beim wetter die
aussichten für die welt der nachrichten
hat jetzt erik illenseer der heute
journal ausblick
[Musik]
am montag will der weltklimarat eyed
peas easy den letzten teil seines neuen
sachstandsberichts veröffentlichen diese
dritte abschnitt bewertet geeignete
politische und technologische maßnahmen
zur begrenzung des klimawandels zum
beispiel die entnahme von co2 aus der
atmosphäre oder was es bringt wenn die
industrialisierte welt ihren lebensstil
ändern etwa bei ernährung mobilität
kommt die allgemeine impfpflicht darüber
soll am donnerstag der bundestag
endgültig entscheiden mehrere vorschläge
stehen zur debatte für wen sie gelten
soll ab welchem alter und wie man sie
umsetzt auch eine verschiebung der
abstimmung auf einen späteren zeitpunkt
ist möglich sollte der vorschlag der
union dazu die mehrheit bekommen
das rennen um den élysée-palast wird am
kommenden sonntag eröffnet mit der
ersten runde der präsidentschaftswahlen
auf platz 3 sehen umfragen derzeit
johnson einen kandidaten der linken auf
zwei die rechtspopulistin marine le pen
die dann voraussichtlich gegen
amtsinhaber max antreten wird bei der
stichwahl am 24 april
wir werden darüber berichten auch
nächste woche wieder auch morgen wieder
und die nächsten nachrichten gibt es
hier gegen 0.30 heute express mit
christopher wehrmann vom gesamten
heute-journal thiemann sie einen
angenehmen sonntagabend
[Musik]